welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down time to hunt the
Korean film follows in the footsteps of
some amazing properties released
recently by the countries such as
Kingdom train to Busan and of course
Best Picture winner parasite that's a
big list to live up to and throughout
this video we'll be giving our thoughts
on the film as well as what we took from
the ending there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out yet that I highly recommend
that you turn off now if you enjoy the
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a breakdown without the
way thank you for clicking this and
let's get into our review of time to
hunt time to hunt opens in a dystopian
imagining of South Korea's future and
it's filled with civil unrest national
debt inequality and a fog that fills the
air due to the effects of global warming
the country is a mess and though it's
clearly decay due to mass amounts of
poverty the film is shot beautifully
from the off we take a trip through the
streets of Korea and even though it's
filled with little dialogue we instantly
get the impression of how the country
currently stands life is hell it's here
that were introduced to our protagonist
Jong Seok who has just been released
from prison after being jailed there for
a heist that happened three years ago
left with little else to think about in
jail he spent the majority of his time
fantasizing about his hashtag best life
and getting to this is the main driving
force for the character with his friends
he wants to plan one last heist that
will make enough money to escape from
the country but as I'm sure you can
guess it isn't going to be easy and
heist movies are often carried on the
back of their core team and time to hunt
really feels like it's pulled together a
group of actors that complement one
another you can instantly see why June
was the leader and why in his absence
the other members have pretty much lived
a lowly existence they too were
criminals that carried out the heist
that June was arrested for and they only
managed to escape because he sacrificed
himself to the police the cash they
managed to make from the job is now
effectively worthless due to the Korean
Won crashing and thus they have to take
US dollars in order to make enough money
to get away June proposes one last heist
on an illegal gambling
stores millions of dollars and though it
seems like a simple job it soon brings
massive repercussions with it using an
insider named sang-soo that works there
they raid the operation but end up
becoming targets themselves it's a
brilliant premise to Center the film
around and though heist movies are often
a dime a dozen time to hunt elevates
itself by the hope within the characters
each one feels like they're at their
lowest point and for people that should
be in the prime of their lives that
stuck to constantly being considered by
them in that force to live day to day
that's one of time to hunts biggest
takeaways I think and similar to
parasite even though the central
characters upper right through lies in
deception
we still gravitate towards them because
we're able to see how bad they have it
we all know it's not going to go well
but Jun wistfully thinks about the
future a better life in paradise that
sounds too good to be true it's often
stay that the wealth divide between the
rich and poor is built upon the idea
that the poor allow it to happen due to
a belief that one day they can be
wealthy too if they just work hard
enough you really get that feeling with
Jun 2 and because of it the character
becomes easy to relate to you due to the
failings of society he finds himself
trapped in a prison of his own making in
which he believes that crime is the only
way that he can get out of it and he
constantly lives in a state of planning
this quote-unquote
one last heist that will allow him to
live a life of luxury gern reunites with
the rest of the group that were part of
the initial heist and together they pull
off the job due to sang-soo who
currently works within the casino the
two other characters are named ki hoon
and jang-ho and I really hope I haven't
butchered their names but we need to
know them in order to talk about things
later in the film it's clear that
they're in over their heads and all our
amateurs that inadvertently open
Pandora's box upon carrying out the job
along with the money they steal various
hard drives that all contain
surveillance on the business's criminal
activities
the gangsters obviously aren't happy
about this and they send a killer
policeman known as Han after them this
is where the titular hunt comes into
play and Han mercilessly tracks down the
group gleefully stalking and playing
games with them
he kills sang-soo and slowly tracks them
across the city no matter how much of a
five-minute head start you get this guy
will catch you he's intimidating as hell
and watching the cat-and-mouse game he
plays with the group
in me Olive Anton from no country for
old men what Han represents is the
authoritarian state and how the rules
don't apply to them
he regularly breaks the law much in the
same way that the group do but there are
no real repercussions for him even after
getting arrested he set free by the
chief of police and the rules of both
the government and gangsters don't
really hamper him in any way now there
is a big twist with that arrest I'll
talk about later in the video but it
basically paints him out as a guy who's
completely invincible and yeah he's not
going down easily a lot of Korean films
I've watched recently have been based
around the notion of the lower class
don't really have the rights that those
in power do and this is definitely
reflected here in the antagonist the
poor are stamped down by those higher up
even if they operate in a similar manner
and hand to me represents the fallacy of
trying to rise above one station they
have an opportunity to escape on a boat
at a harbor but ki hoon returns to his
family and Jun goes with him returning
to their hideout to see that Han has
arrived it leads to one of the tensest
action scenes in the film and it's a
nail-biting showdown for both sides
jang-ho was hit multiple times and he
dies which leaves Jun to go head-to-head
with Han at the docks jr. is wearing an
incredibly strong bulletproof vest but
Han still manages to doubt him and he
goes in for an execution shot luckily
bong seeks twin brother bong soo arrives
seeking revenge the death of his sibling
which we saw Han carry out earlier in
the movie when he was trying to learn
the whereabouts of the group it turns
out that he's the chief of police and he
actually you released Han after he was
arrested so that he could kill him
outside of the law they shoot hands
several times and he seemingly killed
falling into the water on the outskirts
of the location Jun finally gets his
wish to go to Ken ting and he seemingly
gets the life he always dreamed about
however he's still haunted by the deaths
of his friends as well as ki hoons fate
the paradise he was seeking had to be
shared with others and living there with
no one to actually enjoy with clearly
dampens the experience what you really
wanted deep down was a better life for
him and his friends but his actions not
only robbed them of it but also himself
throughout the movie Jun was constantly
given nightmares and it's clear that no
matter how far
where he gets he will be forever
tormented by them running away from
things doesn't actually deal with them
and his hopes of escaping will always be
a pipe dream if he can't get away from
that which haunts him the most he learns
that Hannah survived but rather than
running once more he decides that for
once in his life he will tackle the
problem head-on rather than fleeing from
it very little is known about Han even
his real name but deep down Jun knows
that he won't stop coming for him
the movie ends with us seeing him
practicing his firearm skills and we
also get lip service paid to ki hoon
surviving this was one of the loose ends
that though heavily hinted at we never
actually got any resolution towards but
it does seem that he is indeed alive the
other one that Jun sees is indeed an
illusion you know that there is a
conversation that does kind of highlight
that that he is still out there
we know that the gangs were slowly being
wiped out and it is possible that the
police took out the one surrounding his
home before they went after Han this is
likely how they learned of its location
and were able to find where he was Jun
has to end what he started and instead
of constantly trying to get away from
the problem he must go head-to-head with
it in order to truly find the peace that
he's been seeking all this time whilst
it does set things up for a sequel
personally I'm not sure if it needs one
but if we do get one
I'm very hyped to see Joon and Han going
face to face again now before we get
into the rest of the video I just wanna
let you know we're giving away your free
copy of the marbled face Ori part one
box set to one random subscriber all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts in
the movie in the comment section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of May and the set
will be shipped out from the intro ever
get surprised the best of luck that
everyone who takes part okay so what did
I think of the film overall we'll have
to say I thoroughly enjoyed it and
Netflix have continued to be a life
saver through lock down over the weekend
they've released time to hunt extraction
in afterlife Season 2 and all have been
absolutely brilliant time to hone is a
tense action film that also has a lot of
social commentary and escapism literally
laced throughout it I think it makes it
a really engaging watch I don't know if
it's for everyone but at the moment I'm
struggling to think of a film or TV show
that Korea has put out recently that I
haven't really enjoyed time to hunt is a
really heartfelt and human heist story
that is beautifully shot and well acted
you definitely should check this out if
you're looking for more entertainment
this week and it gets an 8.5 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on time to hunt so comment
below and let me know make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day and if you want something
else to watch we've got a great
breakdown of extraction at the end y'all
over the entire movie and it's ending so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more gonna support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you it there's a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the disk order link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully you see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best now see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]